all right it's no secret the mob the
media rushed to judgment again and got
almost all of the facts wrong about kyle
rittenhouse and while many of their
lives were debunked during the trial and
by the way a lot before the trial some
mob members are still having trouble
letting go they can't help themselves
they're wrong let's see on every major
case oh like trump russia collusion with
russia that never happened uh we have
ferguson missouri we have freddie gray
baltimore maryland cambridge police uva
duke lacrosse
and on and on and on they get it wrong
all the time and they're having a hard
time letting this one go take a look
three people got shot
two people were murdered to me it's
murder i'm sorry the video show him
running each time and turning around
which they said
legally speaking except that he ran that
he came there to agree that's what i'm
saying you shouldn't have that's a
problem
i don't believe in open carry i have a
question for the for the ladies of the
view
now if somebody takes a loaded gun and
points it right at your head
what are you going to do
if somebody chases a mob chases you and
gets you on the ground and they have a
foot about to stomp on your face and
push your face into the pavement
what are you going to do
or somebody uses a skateboard as a
weapon to attack you what are you going
to do there
joining us now 10 weeks in a row number
one on the new york times list american
marxism he is the host of life liberty
and levin
is nationally syndicated radio host
there's a reason i call him the great
one
mark levin a lot of ground here dying to
get your thoughts
first of all why do we care what they
say on the view they have a collective
iq of negative 17. they're like a bunch
of yentas who sit around and
who really cares what they think i
certainly don't um
part of the problem is you asked earlier
the breakdown in law order the breakdown
of law and order has been
institutionalized by the democrat party
and their media it's been
institutionalized by them
and the media is so racist now
we don't have a free press we have a
tyrannical press
all you have to do is spend a couple
hours watching mslsd or cnn what i call
the constipated news network
and you'll see it it's very very quick
they talk about white justice systems
set up for white people that's joy reid
and
her limited brain capacity then there's
another one in there tiffany i think her
name is
she's trying to outdo
joy reid but this is a company msnbc
that's owned by comcast
i just want everybody to know that out
there they own nbc and comcast and att
well they own cnn
so these huge corporations these
corporatists they think they're buying
um
silence by siding with these these
marxists these kooks these radicals
and in fact what's happening is the
media in this country
they're destroying this country
rittenhouse case involved three white
men
all felons that's the commonality one
white teenager written house a white
judge white prosecutors and white
defense counsel and somehow it was
racist that's pretty sick
uh walker shaw you have another felon so
the three people shot in uh in the
rittenhouse case were all felons
the individual who mowed down innocent
human beings the other night he's
another felon who is it that seeks the
felon vote who is it that seeks to have
felons as part of their base who is it
bernie sanders who said that he thinks
people still serving time should vote
whether they're on death row or the
rapist or whatever so this is this is
part of the democrat party base that's
why their media
jump out front and always defend the
felons against earnest americans
and the democrat party campaign for that
vote and the democrat party
and their surrogates and the media they
confuse vigilantism with good
samaritanism
uh
kyle rittenhouse was a good samaritan he
wasn't a vigilante everybody knows what
a vigilante is but here's what the
racist media on msnbc
and cnn did not report that is the
slaughter that takes place in our cities
largely black on black crime largely
young black men killing young black men
it never passes their lips
in this white dominated society it's an
amazing thing crt white dominated
society but we have a real problem of
the kind of mayhem and slaughter that's
taking place in our cities here is a cbs
local in chicago over 30 shootings in
six kill
so let me do something for a few minutes
sean that's a little unusual but you
will not hear
on
self-righteous
msnbc or cnn and haven't at least six
people have died from gun violence in
the city of chicago as of saturday night
the fatal shooting over the weekend a
man was shot and killed another was
wounded in west angle
a 35 year old man was found inside the
residence with a gunshot wound to his
hip a 45 year old was also found in a
parked vehicle outside with gunshot
wounds to the chest and head
35 year old victim was transported to
the chicago fire department by that
department to christ hospital was
initially listed in good condition
a 45 year old victim was transported to
advocate christ medical center where he
was pronounced dead
in another deadly incident a 22 year old
man was shot in the head saturday
afternoon
the victim was standing on the corner
minding his own business when an unknown
person walked up and shot him in the
head the victim was transported to mount
sinai hospital in critical condition and
then died
police also said a 47 year old man was
shot in a drive-by around 2 p.m on
saturday he stood on a sidewalk he
suffered a gunshot wound to the lower
right abdomen he was taken to the
stroger hospital and was pronounced dead
it's all in chicago uh sunday a 19 year
old man was shot in the head uh in in
the uh
let's see your south shore neighborhood
the victim identified as was pronounced
dead at the scene 14 year old boy was
killed in a shooting in the city's
roseland neighborhood police say he was
he was near a sidewalk uh these are all
innocent people being slaughtered in our
big so there's only chicago but we're
worried you see about
vigilantes you see like kyle rittenhouse
who defended himself
shot three felons and then another felon
is out driving uh driving and yes trying
to kill people
uh at a parade a 16 year old boy
suffered a gunshot wound i'm not done uh
on on saturday police said the victim
was walking walking when he heard shots
and felt pain the victim was transported
to the stroger hospital
a 33 year old man was shot during a
robbery police said the victim was
outside when he was shot at multiple
times by an unidentified male offender
who fled the scene he was shot in the
head and in the arm
let's see uh 27 year old man suffered a
gunshot wound in the back of the head
in a roseland neighborhood saturday
morning
the victim was transported to the
advocate christ medical center in
critical condition a man was shot
following a verbal altercation
early saturday morning in the belmont
heights neighborhood and you know what
i've only just gotten started america
here's some more
here's some more here's some more
i just want to know why on ms lsd and
the constipated news network
why they claim to be so concerned
and that they don't cover any of this
if i hadn't read this what i just read
to you would not be on any national
television program
not
one
why aren't people concerned about felons
roaming around why aren't they concerned
about joy reid says uh the whites are
concerned about property rights you know
because that's what the nation was
founded on maybe next time she
negotiates her contract she can remember
that because she seems to be into
property too but all that said
it's not that it's not about a white
dominant society it's not about corrupt
judges or corrupt police or corrupt
juries
it's about a culture in decline
and the culture in decline is led by the
racist media in this country which
appears by these giant corporations
whether it's comcast 18t whether it's
bezos over the washington
compost or whatever it is they cannot
hire enough reprobates malcontents and
miscreants who hate this country who
undermine this nation
who do not care for law enforcement
because when they go home they're not
going into these communities
it's like professional sports they run
around with stuff on their sneakers and
on their shirts and they think they're
revolutionaries meanwhile they support
communist china they won't say a damn
thing about the uyghurs being
slaughtered the christians being rounded
up the tibetans being killed but they'll
talk about slavery that occurred 150 200
years ago we can talk about that but
what about modern day humanity and so
forth no no no
the people on tv they go home you know
people need to know when you go to the
studio you're trying to make a king or a
queen with makeup and all the rest they
go home everything's fine then they show
up for the revolution in front of the
camera then they go back home to their
to their nice neighborhoods and so forth
and so i'm just saying this
the greatest threat we face in this
country right now
is the american media and the democrat
party who are at war with our culture at
war with our society in a war with our
constitutional system mark i got a
question
i have a question before you say that's
it i'm done um one question too late
legal remedy
in a case like this i had nicolas
sandman you know what they did to that
kid
for wearing a maga hat at a at a
pro-life rally and they lied about him
and he's now already settled with media
organizations does kyle rittenhouse have
a case against all these people in the
media that lied about him called them a
white supremacist do you have a case
against joe biden for example
all right let's take biden first based
on the bill clinton case the paula jones
case he absolutely does have a case
against joe biden there is no
presidential immunity because he wasn't
president
he was a private citizen and the supreme
court ruled on that yes you can bring a
civil case
against somebody who becomes president
of the united states based on what
they've done prior to that time
so he would have a case against joe
biden even though he's a public figure
look even though the supreme court has
rewritten the first amendment in a way
that protects reprobates in public
office
you can still overcome it if somebody
makes a definitive statement that you
are a white supremacist and they have no
evidence whatsoever and they had no
evidence at the time
despite all the levels the courts have
put in place
that is a strong case i saw this tiffany
and i don't know her last name on msnbc
even after the trial she talked about
kyle uh being a a something like a young
white supremacist murder
that is a great case to bring against
somebody like her as far as i am
concerned we're not talking about
defending a free press here this
presidency free it's tyrannical this
press is uh is
supporting activities and supporting
movements that are destructive of this
country what i call this american
marxist movement if you're gonna go on
tv and be a bigot a racist a homophobe
and you're gonna do it night after night
after night as far as i'm concerned yes
and i'll tell you something one other
thing
they are destroying or trying to destroy
the character of anybody who doesn't
agree with them so in other words you
can be black you can be brown you can be
red or whatever it is if you don't join
in this marxist revolution that they're
pushing or this critical race theory or
the degrowth movement they call climate
change you don't believe in the
redistribution of wealth from the people
who produce it to the people who don't
from the private sector this this
massive monopoly of a government we have
they start characterizing you and they
use racism there was a study done by a
guy at the heritage foundation
about a year ago it's in my book and he
points out that the use of white
supremacy and the use of racism and so
forth by the media
by the new york times it was up twelve
hundred percent by the washington post
it was fifteen hundred percent
and when they talk about white racists
they're not talking about the klan or
the neo-nazi they're talking about all
white people and including people of
color who love this society and love
this country
and not only that they have an
anti-semite problem too in the media
look how they protect talib
and omar and aoc
and so i think we need to start focusing
on companies like comcast and att and
others we need to start going to their
shareholder meetings we need to start
demanding that they mark i got to roll
the news or they report opinion
but out without all these racist
bastards who go on television whether
they're tenured professors or something
else who go on tv and are lighting fuses
all over the place for which they take
no responsibility and no consequences
that's it again all right that's it
i actually did that at the patriot
awards in your honor